The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: I have
two functions here.
One is add, and one is multiply.
The add function returns
the sum of x plus y.
And the multiply function just
prints the value of x times y,
but doesn't return the value.
Instead, it's going to
implicitly return none
because we don't have any
return statement inside mult.
So there are four lines here.
And the question was how
many total lines of output
will show up if
you run the code?
OK, so how many lines
in the console show up?
So when I do first
add 1, 2, it's
going to go inside this function
here and say-- it says x is 1,
y is 2, and return 3.
So I'm replacing
this line with 3.
But notice I'm never
printing it out.
So this line of code will
not print out anything.
Instead, the next line is
if I print add 2 plus 3,
then I'm going to get 5.
And I'm going to print that out.
So that's one thing
I'm printing out.
The next line says
multiply 3 and 4.
So I'm going to go inside my
mult function and say, x is 3,
y is 4.
So I'm going to print 12
because 3 times 4 is 12.
So that's another thing
that gets printed out.
And I'm not doing anything
with the output-- or sorry, I'm
not doing anything with
the return from mult.
So that line is done.
And the last one
is the trickiest
and it says print mult 4 and 5.
So first I'm going
to go in here.
X is 4, y is 5.
And I'm printing 20.
So that's another print.
And the return of this function
is going to be none, right?
And the main thing here
is I'm going to print
at the return of this function.
So I'm also going
to print out none.
So that's another one.
So in total, I'm going to have
four different things printed
out, the last one
being this none.